there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
would become something more so when they
needed us we could react to the trailers
that they never could
[Music]
the movies are so different other people
get mad at us for not memorizing the
damn source material you're pulling an
all-nighter
damn straight we're pulling an
all-nighter we're gonna be the first
ones to get our trailer reaction up hell
yeah we are we're gonna be Tyrone Magnus
we're gonna beat your less successful
brother Jabba couette we might even be
beyond the tre no one beats beyond the
trailer that's true she is the best she
doesn't even acknowledge us - why should
we acknowledge her we will not
acknowledge grace ran off in any trailer
because we are jealous and she does not
acknowledge us she was born February 5th
1987 has written several comic books but
like hell will we let people know how
much we follow our eye man stay alert
keep tracking notifications and get that
reaction up first I'm right there with
you buddy there is no additional punch
line coming none zip nada cut to
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] I need to change my personality
underoos John
John you there
[Music]
Tyrone what's up man you guys [ __ ] that
a vendor sport for the reaction was the
only way Jackie the Avengers trailer
destroyed
[Music]
hello hello hello mr. Greg
[Music]
I don't feel so good
I don't know what's happening yeah I
mean you're right John I'm sorry
[Music]
[Music]
this would've been a lot of fun at your
grace Randolph was in it well this is a
pleasant surprise
all right guys it's super early in the
morning we're gonna give all our proper
thanks to everyone who helped us out
with that sketch and sure thanks for
being here but come on it's the avengers
portrait let's freaking do this already
avengers endgame
you bet your ass I suppose if you find
this recording don't feel better about
this part of the journeys the end well
just there being adrift in space with
zero I promise that rescue is more fun
that sounds food water went out four
days ago
oxygen allowed out too long morning I
did when I just off I will turn back
here toys
he's talking exactly to his mask stereo
yeah yeah
[Music]
80% of all living creatures
[Music]
Plus friends to us family
he's shaved
[Applause]
[Music]
hello daddy
have a title here was not the games
beginning handful three time of the game
the rooster brothers are such liars and
they said endgame wasn't the yeah
whatever
hello we gotta watch again everybody
it is possible if you find this
recording don't feel bad about this part
of the journey is the end I'm really
liking the town of this trailer guy yeah
and it feels like so much more grounded
it was just the teaser about tomorrow
morning but for some reason I just love
this idea that tony has stranded in
space you know yeah I didn't nebula be
with him yeah strain it in the cave in
the first movie yeah
[Music]
it's a show that impossible to find
enough yeah
he wiped out
you know this this feel like I get wide
open this is just infinity War part two
it feels very different already just
from this the first hours just them
looking somber yeah things we lost
it's gonna be the coolest Jeremy
Renner's been this entire time calls him
Steven here I miss the beer
this is so good I love that logo
effective like this yeah that's
reassembling he nesting
[Applause]
and adds the hope like I love that music
the music seems really like a big
standout because uh I don't know it's
just seems like but also ray of may
because they're watching realm and
everything like that looking at the time
vortex yeah guys we're gonna do a full
trailer breakdown in a minute but
obviously we're all very psyched about
it so keep a lookout for that next
upload because we're gonna really talk
about as much as we can there right
before we wrap this up though I just
want to give a thank you to everyone who
helped us out with that opening sketch
all their links are in the description
box for those who have YouTube channels
want to start off with Kyle either man
from the fan Theory TV channel he's also
the guy who did the dusting effect is
that the official thing they called the
decimation decimation effect so Thank
You Kyle for doing all that hard work
while you were on vacation John Bailey
epic voice guy for doing the intro
narration for us javi koay and achar
occurred for participating Tyrone Magnus
he's somebody Wendy and Dustin from the
movie couple channel ah curse on you
guys know him he's the only one who gets
to survive this time um Dante he's
popular Tara Eriksen a regular reject of
this channel
Tony Gill who did so much of the camera
work for us as well as Olivia Missy I'm
a beautiful girlfriend who did a lot of
this sound for us so thank you guys so
much and Andrew thank you for being here
well what did you think of that Avengers
4 trailer Amanda to live up to the hype
was it worth the long long anticipated
wait I don't think there's ever been any
high for any trailer like this in
history you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell to get notified every time one of
our videos up and check us out on
patreon over there we do weekly Q&A s TV
show reactions for so many shows plus
John does music video coverage and don't
forget to check out Andrew Gordon on the
movie source channel